and Tony Blair says that Labor's
position on brexit is destructive
indecision is he right look one of the
things that I found extraordinary about
your interview with Tony was that in all
of that he did not mention the word
democracy and the fact is and we've seen
it in the polls that you showed up there
about the support in the polls for the
brexit party people in this country are
angry they're angry that the referendum
result has not been delivered on by an
incompetent government and there's a
protest that is being signaled by those
figures thirty four percent saying that
they would go for brexit there's no
policies in this party no policies it's
just one it's that they want to leave
the European Union without a deal now so
this is extraordinary though Sophie
absolutely extraordinary because we
cannot let mr. Nigel Farage redefine
what the referendum was about the
referendum was about leaving the EU now
it wasn't you know at that time there
was no talk of of no deal there's no
talk of going on to WTO terms we were
going to leave with the deal so he's
changed his position on that more than
that if you look at the time of the
referendum he actually held up Norway
Faraj held up Norway as a model of what
Britain could be as an independent
sovereign nation outside of the EU yet a
part of a single market so what we're
seeing is a huge amount of anger but
what he is subtly doing or are less than
subtly doing mr. Faraj is now trying to
calm the British people that what they
voted for and hasn't been delivered is
actually now what he says it is and it's
not so in listening to what you're
saying there about democracy about what
people voted for is labour a Pro brexit
party now tony was right
to say that we have always as a party
and most of the mps in the labour party
believes that we should
have remained in the European Union we
campaign for that at the referendum and
most of the Labour MPs voted to remain
but when that referendum came in we said
look we made your promise we made you a
promise that what you decided is what we
would do and when we went to the Supreme
Court when when it came to the Supreme
Court about triggering article 50 the
Supreme Court got it absolutely right
the Supreme Court said the referendum
decided that we should leave the EU it
is now for Parliament to decide how we
leave the either just be crystal clear
labor the labor position is that we
should leave that's what we've been
trying to do with these negotiations
with the government that's why we're
there we look what happened was the the
Conservative Party Teresa Mays party
could not negotiate a decent deal with
Europe and then because it was such a
bad deal they couldn't get it through
Parliament we've been saying now since
what February of last year that we
believe there is an alternative way of
doing this are you trying to are you
trying to bail out the Tories they as
you said you look and we're trying to
bail out the country because of the
Tories failure of course because we
believe that we have to act in the best
interest of the country but that's not
just simply the economic interest which
we are trying to protect with a customs
union that we're trying to protect by
ensuring that the the rights and
protections that we have in the
workplace are always maintained and
uplifted we are we are absolutely clear
about that but on the on the other side
we believe it's important that as a
country we respect the promises that we
made and the democratic decision of the
people and we're the only party the only
party that is actually trying to appeal
not to this half of the population or
that half of Tory's name would probably
argue that she is trying to do the same
thing I mean you can disagree with her
methods can't you you can disagree with
her what she's doing but she would argue
that she's trying to do that as well by
putting forward a deal
you you ought to mr. Fong has singularly
failed and she needs to recognize that
and and that's why ultimately after we
should have you know after the date we
were supposed to have left the EU she
had to then come to the Labour Party and
say you know what guys I think maybe
maybe you might be right after all that
if we can protect rights protect our
environment and and and actually go for
a customs union maybe we can actually
get this deal over the line and through
Parliament now I don't know whether this
deal is going to work because you saw
what happened last week you saw the way
in which the government broke the
confidentiality agreement that they had
about those talks and what you've seen
is different cabinet ministers and
different putative successors to Teresa
may all going in different dial come on
so the labor front benches as well let's
be honest no no no look we're talking
about their view on brexit under
negotiations right and and what they've
been doing is they have been out bidding
each other in the leadership war to try
and be the most right-wing they can
possibly be because they think that that
is what the Tory grassroots will vote in
the Senate now I know I'm keen to talk
as well about the us-china well can I
just finish up that though and and and
that is to say that we don't know at
this stage even if we could negotiate a
deal what we don't know is whether the
successor to Teresa may would actually
deliver on it and that's one of the big
sticking points that we have okay now we
have seen an escalation of the us-china
trade war as the shadow international
trade secretary mean how concerned are
you by what saying okay I'm hugely
concerned on two fronts and I'm
concerned because of the global
implications of this what you have is a
super power in the United States that
has had dominance on the global stage
for the past 50 60 years and you have
the emergence of China and it's not
simply a one on one trade war here
you've seen with the emergence of China
and their belt and Road initiative that
this is also just
and it's being played out at two levels
this fight between America and the u.s.
is being played out at an economic level
with the the terrace that Trump put on
Chinese goods just last week the
increase in the towers from 10 to 25%
now that in itself could knock 65
billion dollars of American GDP so this
is this is huge in terms of of the way
it can affect the world and world growth
will suffer as a result of this but if
it escalates both as an economic and a
geostrategic conflict and then the
impact on growth could be enormous we
could be seeing in fact some of the
banks now are modeling figures that
suggest that there could be a the in the
next five years a 17% reduction in
global GDP that's that's bigger than the
2008 financial crisis and then just
finally as well I'm keen to get your
thoughts as well on the Sunday Times
Rich List in the newspapers today Jeremy
Corbyn has said it's a reminder of the
grotesque inequality that we see a lot
of people knows less they will be
employing an awful lot of people and
paying an awful lot of tax and shouldn't
be making them feel welcome and it's not
a matter of not fake making them feel
welcome look I I remember have you
probably don't Margaret Thatcher Fred
you know the the highest rate of tax
under Margaret Thatcher and for nine
years I think it was 60% 60% we're not
talking anything like that what we're
saying is look and it's fine for people
to to make money and employ people
that's great we want a thriving economy
but they should pay a fair rate of tax
and and that's why if you look at you
know what we were announcing last week
was to say why should it be that a 17
year old kid is getting paid half of
what somebody who's 24 is getting paid
in the same job now those those low
age-related minimum wages that's not
acceptable you know and it's certainly
not acceptable you know when there are
people who are making bill
millions of pounds and not paying those
people properly because we have people
who are in work but on food banks in
work but needing support from the rest
of society taxation is the price we pay
for civilization and I think everybody
should pay a fair rate of tax okay
very good now we're out of time thank
you very much being on the program
Thanks